Olá se você comer pão não dirija parece
uma brincadeira certo mas imagine que
você está na sua casa come o sanduíche
com pão de forma e depois pega o seu
carro para sair de repente Enquanto Você
dirige você parar numa blitz e precisa
fazer o teste do bafômetro você faz o
teste tranquilamente Afinal você só
comeu um sanduíche no máximo bebeu um
café ou suco mas paraa sua surpresa você
foi pego no teste do bafômetro por
possível embriaguez mas esa aí você se
pergunta eu não consumi álcool talvez
você nem goste de bebidas alcoólicas
como é que é isso possível segundo uma
pesquisa feita pela Associação
Brasileira de Defesa do Consumidor a
Proteste algumas marcas de pães de forma
possuem o alto teor alcoólico e uma
quantidade de álcool que pode fazer com
que você seja pego no teste do bafômetro
pessoal essa pesquisa da Proteste que
examinou o teor alcoólico dessas marcas
de pães de forma vendidas nos
supermercados aqui no Brasil foi
noticiada pelo portal G1 e por outros
veículos de comunicação eu vou deixar o
link da matéria completa na descrição do
vídeo essa pesquisa incluiu várias
marcas de pães e vocês estão vendo agora
na tela as marcas que foram avaliadas os
resultados indicaram que seis dessas
marcas iadas poderiam ser classificadas
como alimentos
alcoólicos se essa classificação
existisse para pães para vocês terem uma
ideia o pão da visconte apresentou uma
porcentagem de álcool de
3,3 por enquanto o pão na valduc
registrou 1,1 de teuro alcoólico mas
você deve estar se perguntando como isso
é possível porque há essa quantidade de
álcool nos pães de forma o processo de
fer ação que faz o pão crescer e ficar
fofinho gera álcool mas a maior parte
desse álcool evapora durante o cozimento
do pão quando ele vai para o forno o que
está acontecendo segundo a Proteste é
que as empresas estão utilizando álcool
adicional para conservar os produtos e
evitar que eles mofem o mofo é um
problema sério na indústria alimentícia
especialmente para pães e bolos causando
perdas significativas na prod
para evitar essas perdas e aumentar a
durabilidade do pão na prateleira as
empresas começaram a adicionar um
produto antimofo diluído em álcool e
essa quantidade de álcool deveria ser
controlada para que fosse a mínima
possível no entanto o estudo mostrou que
isso não está sendo bem regulamentado ou
fiscalizado segundo a legislação
brasileira bebidas com teor de etanol
acima de
0,5 deveria deam ser classificadas como
alcoólicas pensando por esse lado alguns
desses pães deveriam vir com aviso de
produto alcoólico Mas isso não acontece
agora imagine que essa porcentagem de
álcool pode até influenciar um teste de
bafômetro os níveis acima de 0,04 MG por
l no bafômetro são considerados
infrações ou crimes de trânsito a
protesta alertou que consumir duas
fatias de pães dessa as marcas com alto
terror alcoólico pode fazer com que o
motorista ultrapasse o limite legal do
teste de bafômetro bem Todas as empresas
responderam que adotam rigorosos padrões
de segurança alimentar e qualidade em
todos os seus produtos e na cadeia de
fornecimento e afirmam seguir toda a
legislação e regulamentação algumas
disseram que não foram notificadas sobre
o referido estudo nem sobre a
metodologia utilizada então não podem
comentar muito sobre a questão Vamos
então acompanhar para saber mais
informações porém não podemos ignorar
essa informação porque existem muitos
problemas relacionados ao álcool mesmo
que sej em pequenas quantidades Ainda
mais se falarmos da combinação do álcool
com carboidratos simples presentes
nesses pães é importante lembrar que o
álcool consumido diariamente mesmo em
pequenas quantidades agora possivelmente
na na fma de pão pode levar a alterações
hepáticas em algumas pessoas isso se
agrava quando o álcool vem acompanhado
de carboidratos simples como é o caso do
pão podendo levar a condições como simo
metabólica e esteatose hepática a famosa
gordura no fígado Além disso não podemos
esquecer que os pães de forma
industrializados frequentemente contém
ingredientes que podem representar
riscos à saúde esses pães são ricos em
açúcares gordura vegetal hidrogenada
sódio e aditivos
químicos pessoal a fermentação excessiva
de carboidratos simples vindos desses
pães agora agravada por um possível teor
alcoólico pode causar também sintomas
como inchaço abdominal gases e dores
especialmente se você tiver um
crescimento excessivo de bactérias
intestinais a longo praso o consumo
exagerado de pães processados pode
aumentar o risco de doenças crônicas
como é o caso de obesidade diabetes tipo
do doenças inflamatórias intestinais e
também doenças cardíacas a maioria dos
pães industrializados contém glúten e
são feitos de farinha de trigo refinada
o pão que a gente come hoje em dia não é
o mesmo de antigamente o trigo foi
alterado de forma genética modificado ao
longo dos anos para aumentar a
produtividade isso foi mudando a
composição da principal proteína
problemática que é o glut GL tornando
ela mais difícil de ser processada pelo
corpo e não podemos esquecer do uso de
agrotóxicos no cultivo de várias
culturas trigo por exemplo é muito
utilizado o glúten pode causar
inflamação no corpo e essa inflamação
pode se manifestar de várias formas como
enxaquecas dor de cabeça intensa existem
desordens causados pelo glúon e pelo
trigo como a doença celíaca reações
alérgicas a taxia cerebelar tubo de
movimento dermatite herpetiforme e
sensibilidade ao glúten de forma non
celica que engloba vários sintomas então
é muito importante pensar em diminuir o
consumo desse tipo de produto mas se
você ama pão e não consegue ficar sem a
dica é primeiro tenta diminuir o consumo
e buscar alternativas melhores existem
padarias especializadas em pães com
fermentação lenta que melhora a
digestibilidade do pão e outra dica é
buscar marcas de pães feitos com outras
farinhas integrais e sem glúten
geralmente você encontra essas marcas em
padarias artesanais que tem intenção de
oferecer um alimento menos problemático
mais saudável sem glúten e sem lácteos
assim você pode ter a consciência de
estar consumindo um produto de alta
qualidade se você não consegue ficar sem
pão prefira os pães de padaria pergunte
sobre os ingredientes usados e evite os
pães de pacotinho Supermercado
Ok você também pode fazer o seu próprio
pão em casa é uma ótima opção busque
receitas da internet mesmo que seja com
trigo fazer em casa vai ser muito mais
saudável do que consumir um produto pré
industrializado Agora vamos esperar para
saber mais informações sobre essa
questão do teoro alcoólico nos pães
industrializadas Parece piada né pessoal
mas não é qualquer novidade eu venho
aqui e trago para vocês um grande abraço
um beijo no coração e você é
feira compartilhe os vídeos faço bem a
vida de alguém pode mudar também no
canal do T além do Semar